Michael [ __ ] what's up buddy here guys
going on good to see you good I'm well
how you doing good
hungry yeah yes oh gosh room service
what can you believe that's ridiculous
it's a good day no multi-million dollar
company this is a ability for
billion-dollar company five billion five
billion so Conor McGregor's running
around give me like a piece of the
company don't get me started at least
have some room so just shoot someone's
ass out pretty good that's sounding
wrong hi why did you shoot someone's ass
off or what because there's no [ __ ]
range service man
yeah that's cuz no come on you yellow
for it no or the usual a UFC yeah
schedule I'm Madonna on the road like I
have to have a hotel that has this and
that and room service is one of the
things I have to have it absolutely how
it helps I'm gonna want ahead of me I'm
a hungry mind push your button anyway
you're kind of a big start right in the
UFC be treating you like a big star
don't get me started
so you by the way what you I just you
might be up a little bit by self you
feel that you left your uh your passport
what happened your passport no my path
nothing is in my room all you forgot to
bring yeah okay I was on vacation in
Maui recently and my car was broken into
they stole all my ID so I'm waiting for
my new ID to come with me I don't know
walk around with my passport if I lose
my passport I'm kind of screwed right
okay you know you know what I'm saying
yeah definitely yeah they got your
driver's license and a bunch of stuff
driver's license everything everything
what I need so Maui in Maui can you
believe it paradise some of the guns but
yeah there you go
so yeah but there's a guy who can really
fight doesn't it frustrate you when you
come back to your car and go I wish I
would have been here while this was
happening 1 million percent look at this
here's my room service yes finally yeah
Anthony have you ever tried doing a live
radio show whilst eating an omelet and
drinking coffee we do it's gonna be
fantastic guys we've had it yet they
argue but I'll eat this out there yeah
the audience is never particularly happy
with that
now it doesn't turn out well so you know
you doing in Maui question will you park
somewhere also up doing the bamboo hike
we would dissipate all afternoon we came
back
long day got lost in the bloody jungle
came back finally to civilization to
find out that we've been robbed
yeah that's it you know no no big story
really it's violating though I had a
cart broken into one time years ago like
I had like this little fanny pack I used
to wear I'm a big fan EPAct guy you say
I bet it looked good it did it really
does it's very comfortable easy travel
are you a fanny pack guy cost yeah I am
no okay yeah used to be yeah I I tucked
it under the seat and I saw homeless guy
walking by and he looked and something
said move the car he just watched you do
that I came back in the window is broken
and you feel violated when someone has
been in your [ __ ] it's a really weird
feeling I mean someone has taken your
stuff and it's amazing out were like I
what I was doing nights here there would
be times where I park on the street down
by like NBC and I get out of here at
like midnight one o'clock in the morning
or something like that and I just like I
would get out there and the car people
would line up the cars cuz you can park
for free overnight yeah more than once I
saw a guy just walking down the line of
cars and every single car he passed he
just pulled on the door just to see if
any of them were unlocked every single
car he's trying to open every day yeah
yeah I'll be honest I didn't really
bother me and you know about the whole
thing yeah you know I mean my wife was
kind of pissed I said listen we've been
together 18 years first time we've ever
been robbed you know on this master
rental car window and took a wallet with
no caching it's not the end of the world
how great is life for you now though I
mean you you're fighting for so long and
you have this this amazing kind of
resurgence and I you're the middleweight
champion and you're fighting it in one
of the biggest nights of the year George
st. Pierre's combat did you think what
happened was you know GSP would find it
welterweight and and Dana I guess was
not happy with tyron woodley performance
against Demian Maia and he's like I'm
not giving you that fight he said it
publicly and now you're going to fight
with Jesus people the fight was on the
fight was off about three times I think
so yeah I mean to be honest I was kind
of still hoping that I would get matched
up with George George is a big star you
know and for my legacy as a fighter you
want to fight the best guys he's a
legend you know you're still competing I
was coming out of retirement
obviously stepping
weight class was a tall order for him
but you know when when I'm retired I
want to know if all the best guys in
George st. Pierre
Anderson Silva Luke Rockhold done hands
on victories over all these people and
they're all legends so for me for my
legacy it's kind of a big deal obviously
Madison Square Garden is an iconic venue
so I can't wait November 4th CDs go on
sale this week I believe and yeah I'm
really really excited about the whole
thing yeah the fact that it's finally in
New York in the GAR it just does feel
like a special thing God going to
Madison Square Garden to see yeah you
could we waited for for so long and now
that it's actually happening to go there
and you're you're headlining that the
second event they've had them it's a
huge huge night yeah no it is it is a
sound very low-key very low-key I mean
it's been a lot of hard work over the
years you know I mean I've been doing
martial arts ever since I was eight
years old and yeah you know it's all led
to this moment and as I said can't wait
November 4th George's coming I mean took
him a while to grow a set of balls
hopefully I mean he's been getting ready
for this comeback for around 2 3 years
now so we're hopefully he's man enough
now he's not gonna pull out of this one
how I remember we had a press conference
at the start of the year then he didn't
want to do it and then this you know
whatever sauce out George please if you
you know I think we've signed bout
agreements so we're good
is it hard for you to get ready for a
guy that you I don't know how well you
know him but like Henderson you had so
you wanted to avenge a loss you know
Anderson is Anderson is it hard for you
to get up for a guy that you've had no
history with other than you have to win
the fight yeah I like George we trained
together a long time ago I like George
st. Pierre is a nice guy but ultimately
at the end of the day once once you're
competing you know then you know it's
rivalry and not just that it's not just
like a normal sport if I lose it hurts
yeah you know it's not like we're losing
a game of football here you know if I
lose I'm gonna lose the fight I'll lose
my belt and I'm gonna get embarrassed in
front of the entire world so no it's not
hard to get up and train and this and
that I mean I'm eight weeks out now
fight camp is about to start obviously
this is a slight interruption doing all
this stuff but it's a necessary evil go
home tonight and yeah that's our
disappearance fight camp come back
November 4th as I say in there whoop
some ass when you have it if you have a
lot like when you I always wonder what
happens after somebody loses a fight
whatever the reason is
and you go in the back and your guys are
there and you have to see your wife
what does she say to you like hey it's
okay or is there a certain way she acts
that she just knows this is how we get
through the loss I don't know and it's
not like I'm that used to losing that
suffice and I just go out and get drunk
if I win a fire I'm celebrating if I
lose a fight I'm drowning my sorrows so
either way
yeah listen you know at the end of the
day when you sign up to fight someone's
gonna win and someone's going to lose
and you've got to be man enough to
accept both eventualities you know if
you win that's great if you lose you
gotta be a man about it you know you see
some people and the back there and the
crying their eyes out and listen and
it's like dude get over it because if
you don't want the other guy would be in
the same situation so you gotta accept
both both outcomes you know I mean yeah
do you want to win yes
are you disappointed yes is it the end
of the world no do you have to stop
drinking during training yeah absolutely
of course you have that you don't go
hand in hand so that's another thing too
like once the fights over win or lose
you're done training start drinking get
me a drink quick I can have a beer
anytime I like but a lot of my friends
used to say I'm from a small town you
know and there's not a lot to do there
and they're like I don't know you do
that I don't know you stopped drinking
for eight weeks it's like what do you
mean is I get to compete in the sport
that I love right on a world stage you
know I could always go to a bar any time
I want when I'm retired were you always
a talker because like there are a lot of
guys who are fighters they don't really
like you know they let their actions do
the talking yeah like George yeah George
yeah yeah they're quiet guys they come
in and you know we have tons of fighters
on the radio there's no say to us by the
way if we if you could only get one of
the guys in which one do you want they
asked us if we would want I like George
but Jesus of the - George will say a lot
of vanilla things you know none of it
really matters am have you always been a
talker I mean I guess I mean I've always
been an idiot
you try me I I sometimes speak before I
think but at the end of the day it's
entertainment
Italy crazy - you've got to let people
know like I was with Demetrius Johnson
who's the flyweight champion
and we did a media tour one day and and
he wouldn't even say that he was gonna
win the fight because and I said why he
said well if I don't win the fight I'm
gonna look stupid
I said yeah but you've got to be man
enough and have the courage to say that
yes I know if I don't win the fight I
might look stupid but who gives a [ __ ]
I'm gonna win this fight and I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say I'm gonna finish you
it's also such a good way of selling a
fight like there's so much more money in
shit-talking I sure when you can back it
up and most of these guys can back it up
that I don't understand why most well
the fighters are not [ __ ] talking oh
yeah but you've got to be genuine and if
not you right then then don't
you can't fake it it's gotta be real and
if you try to fake it then you come
across a bit corny and a bit weird you
know and some people just cause I mean
fighters some are very intelligent
some are josée all those said you know
this is I'm gonna start talking now
because that's how you sell a fight and
say no you don't do that then be
yourself that's like spanking a girl and
you're having sex and going no I don't
really mean this but I know you like
it's like you just [ __ ] ruin the vibe
you're actually did anything wrong here
I'm just you know just for the moment
yeah of ruining it yeah you just be
yourself and fortunately I've always
been a dick so Conor always says like I
tend to like Conor more when he loses
because I like the way he handles yeah
sure he'll come out and he'll just seem
to be home but when you've had your ass
kicked
I guess that really is all you can do
but for you it's like okay that everyone
knows you expect to win anyway because
you're going out and fighting so even if
you say it doesn't matter we I mean your
hopes who win
I mean yeah you don't expect to it I
mean you know there's no guarantees here
you know you're walking out there
there's nothing fake about it you know
it's anything can happen you know and
there's so many different you know
things at stake I mean you know you you
sleep when you sort of should have you
know when you Bob me instead of we've
you know whatever you get cold with a
little shot and can change everything
you can have the best fight camp of your
life you put one foot wrong and you can
lose the fight so you don't expect to
win you hope to win you think you're
gonna win you're confident in winning
but until you get your hand raised you
don't know what's gonna happen
and you've been very outspoken too about
guys who are using any type of
performance-enhancing rightly so yeah
yeah you are the guys who really is
does not mince words about it which is
no absolutely I mean there's no place
for in this for you know I mean number
one was supposed to be martial artists
you know and that goes against their
whole you know very you know concept of
martial arts at its core you know going
out there and taking steroids and
enhancing your body it's illegal it's
not allowed it's Bandhan and it's
dangerous you know we're not trying to
put a hole so I part of me a ball in a
basket in like that were trying to knock
each other out you know and if you're
taking steroids he's only gonna be a
matter of time sadly before somebody
passes away so the UFC doing a great job
of testing everybody and people are
getting caught left right and center so
yeah I'm very happy it's a pain in the
ass when the trainer put my house at six
o'clock in the morning want to test me
though we did two weeks ago on Labor Day
I'm not dude seriously I'm in bed 6 a.m.
you wanna [ __ ] test me so yeah they
take blood all the time or they let you
in yeah all they take your and whatever
they want you have to give them whatever
they want it yeah exactly yeah otherwise
it goes down as a failed test oh that's
a divorce it is first you show up every
single day my whereabouts and and if if
my worried about differ from what is on
the email then I have to tell them in a
way it's like a parole almost well yeah
I'll let the check in with the parole
officer every day do you think no the
emails every day me the world I'm not
[ __ ] checking in with you solder
everything if you get me you get me if
you don't were you surprised that Jon
Jones got popped again I'm shocked
yeah or shocked I don't if I was
surprised oh I guess the two are the
same but you know it was definitely
shocking but then when you look at it
and you break it down as a huh yeah
maybe it's one of those things you just
can't believe it like you can see
there's gotta be a mistake like no one
would be that it's like a guy getting
out of jail for bank robbery and
literally doing it on his way home for
AZ yeah it's absolutely insane but the
thing is unfortunately steroids and I
hate that we go on about stuff like I've
got a big fight coming up and we're
talking about negative stuff like this
but it's a psychological weakness it is
and they kind of get addicted to it they
can't help me anything well I've been so
successful with it without it I'm not
gonna be able to compete you know now so
I'm not seeing did his whole career but
that is the case for a lot of people UFC
being the big company that it is like do
they ever give you [ __ ]
about the stuff that you say I'm like
your podcast or radio shows or anything
like that you are my wife gives me a lot
of [ __ ] okay
Michael please please try a little
harder
no no not really I don't I've never said
anything to me ever no no Wow
and I'm not that bad yeah Luis Gomez
probably says a lot worse than he does
he doesn't you know I mean a lot of his
clothes you know it's a little close to
the edge dude really yeah every time no
I mean I've never said a word that's
great you are and to plug we only have
two minutes with Michael left but to
plug the fight to its the metaphor that
the garden November 4th middleweight
championship you against George st.
Pierre his first fight and what is it
three Nate you almost four years almost
four years and George wanted this fight
really badly and god bless him
god bless Amy because they fallen into
the trap falling into the trap of
thinking that you can beat me a lot of
people do that they watch me on TV this
guy isn't that good it's a very
different thing when you're in there so
thank you George
thank you for giving me an easy payday
it's nice you think of that that's crowd
of me is he really thinking that this
guy's not that good
we trained together a long long time ago
and I couldn't wrestle back then I still
can't wrestle now really I'm more you
know I'm a kickboxer and he just out
wrestled me consistently and I think he
thinks that I'm that same guy from what
was 12 years ago so I mean George is a
clever guy he's very intelligent so but
still yeah I think that is his thought
process behind the whole thing
how long do you think the fights gonna
be I think I take him out of there I'm
gonna try for the round one but I
definitely stopped him he doesn't go the
distance Wow
not at all and the pre-cell is tomorrow
by the way Square Garden yes and where
do they go for tickets Travis do you
know that presale tomorrow is for is
Fight Club
you see general and then general on
sales Friday okay general on sale is
Friday morning for this this is
obviously it's gonna sell out yeah it's
a huge fight it's also fighting when the
boys on there and you know it's a great
fight card oh he's fighting Jorge Master
Don right now that's right yeah is there
another fight that they might be
announcing another card so I don't know
I don't know but say you know mean
George is a big main event so I'm
excited for that and as I say
unfortunate for him you know I'm gonna
wreck he's coming out of retirement
plans but say yeah should be good she'll
be good looking forward to it yeah I
like George but I
think you're gonna win that fight and I
want to see you in that fight because
you're fun you find me every time you
call an UFC and filter yours one of most
honest guys it's just so refreshing
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there yeah
guys try to say the right thing instead
of just being honest and saying what
they want to say yeah so I agree also we
were talking before you got in I thought
it was really funny that time you're
flipping off Conor McGregor no I'm John
Romero Joe remain supposed to fight and
yeah he was like you know they calling
me out from the audience and you just
see like bids like instead of like just
like trying to you know bow up and just
be this sort of stoic tough-guy Bisbing
it's just in the audience flippin like
you do you know go [ __ ] yourself exactly
so yeah I guess me and that guy maybe
one day I get it on but for now all
efforts are on George